well this tweet got our attention last
night todd gurley no longer a member of
the rams and still not officially a
member of the falcons although the
falcons have announced the transaction
still waiting for that physical
gurley tweeted at the rams past due send
me money asap clay matthews chimes in a
little bit later in the evening you and
me both tg better get some interest with
that too here's what's going on
todd gurley had a 7.75 million dollar
roster bonus that was due to be paid by
march 30. the rams have not paid it clay
matthews has a two million dollar roster
bonus fully guaranteed due from the rams
by march 30. the rams didn't pay him now
as it relates to matthews apparently
there's an argument to be made that the
rams are waiting to see
what he earns elsewhere because they
have an ops an offset
uh
right under the contract where if he
makes two million with someone else they
don't know him anything the contract and
i've seen it it's not as clear as it
could be and i think they should just
cut the check and if clay matthews makes
money back later then he refunds the
money to the rams with gurley my
understanding is they're clearly in the
wrong they just flat out have not paid
him chris how in the world does this
happen i asked the rams for comment they
have no response no statement on either
guy so we at least did the responsible
thing but chris how does this happen
where a team just stiffs a player not
just one player but two players both
fairly high profile
yeah i i don't know you know i don't now
listen i could say this i was at the
denver broncos in 2009 and they had some
cash flow problems and they didn't pay
me my signing bonus until like october
or september now i got the money and you
know all's good in the end but you know
sometimes these teams just don't have
the liquid cash i'm like i ask you i
mean do you think this has something to
do with you know
uh season ticket money not coming in
right now because of the cobit 19
pandemic and maybe a lack of cash flow i
mean could that possibly be it
i i look i don't know all i know is stan
kroenke is one of the richest men in the
world but that doesn't mean he
necessarily allocates large chunks of
his cash more than he needs to for the
budgets over which kevin kevin demoff
the ceo of the team has control so it
may be more complicated than that it may
just be the simple reality that hey
what's the worst that's going to happen
they file a grievance we have to pay
them the money anyway but from the
standpoint of how it affects how other
players view the rams that's where it
becomes problematic if the word gets
around that the rams are going to stiff
you then you're not going to sign with
the rams if you have options when you're
a free agent chris
well yeah that's where you know i think
about right away if i'm sitting there
leonard floyd uh or a sean robinson who
is yet to have a deal finalized with the
rams right here in free agency i'm a
little scared when i see things like
that i'm going damn are they going to
honor this contract what's going to
happen so you're right it's not a good
look for them and it's certainly not
going to make players trust them a whole
lot
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports